xbox is becoming the new home of
activision blizzard let's talk about it
following reports microsoft has now
officially announced it has acquired
activision blizzard in a deal set to be
valued at nearly 70 billion dollars and
to think just a couple weeks ago we
thought the take two and zynga deal was
gonna be the largest acquisition of the
year in a statement xbox boss phil
spencer said quote we are incredibly
excited to have the chance to work with
the amazing talented dedicated people
across activision publishing blizzard
entertainment binocs demon wear digital
legends high moon studios infinity ward
king major league gaming radical
entertainment raven software
sledgehammer games toys for bob treyarch
and every team across activision
blizzard toys for bob huh well i guess
it's safe to say that crash bandicoot
won't be in a playstation all-stars 2.
spencer went on to say that microsoft
will add as many acty blizz games to
game pass as it can and the acquisition
will help accelerate their cloud gaming
plans in its own statement activision
blizzard confirmed that microsoft will
pay 95 dollars per share to acquire
activision blizzard for a total payout
of 68.7
billion if the deal goes through in
buying activision blizzard microsoft
will also take ownership of massive
franchises like call of duty warcraft
diablo and overwatch as well as
activision blizzard's esports endeavors
that means microsoft will have a total
of 30 internal game development studios
following the acquisition as a part of
the buyout microsoft shared an image of
the quote gaming leadership team with
phil spencer at the top as ceo of
microsoft gaming until the deal closes
microsoft and activision blizzard will
act independently if and when it does
close the activision blizzard team will
report to phil activision blizzard ceo
bobby kotick who has been in the middle
of ongoing lawsuits regarding sexual
harassment and discrimination will
remain ceo of activision blizzard
however according to the wall street
journal the companies have agreed that
bobby will depart once the deal closes
the site goes on to say kotek told
microsoft he will quote always be
available to ensure that we are going to
have the very best integration in his
statement spencer said quote we deeply
value individual studio cultures we also
believe that creative success and
autonomy go hand in hand with treating
every person with dignity and respect we
hold all teams and all leaders to this
commitment we're looking forward to
extending our culture of proactive
inclusion to the great teams across
activision blizzard microsoft's proposed
acquisition of activision blizzard is
subject to the standard closing
conditions and a regulatory review as
well as an approval from activision
blizzard's shareholders the deal has
already been approved by the board of
directors at microsoft and activision
blizzard if all goes according to plan
the deal is expected to close in fiscal
year 2023 so what do you think of this
news and should playstation be worried
let me know in the comments
[Music]